the race is ultimately going to be
Donald Trump versus Ron DeSantis I think
he can be healthy we just got to stay
focused on beating Democrats uh you know
a lot of folks back home pretty
confident Donald Trump's going to win
the primary
um and they want to see the competition
you know at some level but they also
want to everybody to stay focused on
beating Democrats instead of beating
each other up yeah the other the other
aspect of this I'm very glad Ron's
running so as critical as I'm going to
be about the way that they're announcing
I I like more competition I think we
need that we need more Democrats RFK and
Biden we need to see those guys debating
we need to see Trump and DeSantis
debating I'm very happy about it yeah I
mean I love what DeSantis is doing in
Florida part of what concerns me is just
how damaging it can be to any
politician's reputation to go up against
Trump and how good he is at just ripping
these people to shreds it's one of his
very strong talents yeah